なんか色が落ちるのが早いな・・・
一回も染めてないんですけど
あんな黒かったのにもう茶色
はじめしゃちょーです
今日のお昼に東京から静岡に帰ってきたんですけども
明日の朝の新幹線で東京です
ちょっと、ちょっとばたばたしてますが明日も東京頑張っていきましょおおおおお　どおおおおお
みなさんこちらをご存知でしょうか？
たぶんね、たぶん学校とか会社とかの身体測定かな 身体測定とかに使われたと思うんですけども
こちら 血圧計でございます。
オムロンデジタル自動血圧計
多分見たことある人いると思うんだけども
まぁシンプルにこの中に腕をつっこむと血圧が分かるというものでございます
これはね たぶんね かなり正確なものです
そもそも血圧が何かはわかりません
血圧ってなんなんだろう
実際血圧ってなんなんだろうって思ってさそもそも血圧を測る意味がわからん
ほうほうほう
血圧とは血液の圧力によってこう、押される力のことで心臓から送り出される、その血液ね？
血の量とか血管の硬さとかによって決まるらしいです
血液の量が多ければ血圧が上がって
血管がやわらければ…血管がやわら…血管の硬さが、
ん～　　　ふっふ
俺わかんない
まぁ要するに血圧とはまぁ簡単に言いますよ 簡単に言いますと
まぁ血液が全身にこう送り出される時の血管にかかる圧力のことでございます
で、この圧力がなんか基本値以上の状態が続く状態を高血圧といって
頭痛とかめまいとかが起きるらしいでございます
というわけでみなさん頭痛とかめまいとか肩こりを感じた人よかったら１回、血圧測ってみたらいかがでしょうか
っていう話じゃなくて
ひとまず電池
なんか昔よくやってたんですよね
血圧を測る検査の時に友達と高い数値を出した方が勝ちって言うのをやってて、
血圧が高いやつがなんか俺の中で強いってイメージがあった。
数値的にね、戦闘力があるとみなされてて、俺達の仲間の中では血圧が高いやつは強いと言われていた。
バカ丸出しだったな。
一回計ってみましょう。まずは一回真面目にはかります。
わあ・・・あれ？あらら・・・あらら・・・あらら、もう･･･なんかよく分かんなくなっちゃった。　いいんじゃね？これで。たぶんこれでいいっしょ
なんかもう計っちゃっていい感ありますな、早速はかってみまっしょう！
背筋を伸ばして、心臓と同じ高さにして、腕をこう乗せる。
血圧計を手前に寄せる。こんな感じですかね？　　開始！
ヴィぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃ　チッ　ヴォぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ
程良い締め付けが・・・彼に快楽を与えた。
はぁ・・・・おおおお待って、待って結構結構結構強ない？
お！来ました！ハイスコアです！ハイスコア！ハイスコア！
最高血圧が１２９最低血圧が７１でございます。
これが今のおいらのスコア
ぺらっ　ぺらっ　　　　ぺらっ
最高血圧が1３５以上
最低血圧が８５以上だと
高血圧の可能性があるみたいです。
129はいたって正常な血圧みたいですね。
最低血圧がちょっと低いぐらいですね、僕は
健康みたいです。よかった・・・
いや、こういうのほんとに計っとくの大事ですからね。
んで今回僕がやりたいのは、自らの力で最高血圧の数値を上げれるんじゃ無いかと僕は思いまして
なるべく僕の中での最高血圧数値を叩き出してみようと思います。
もう、めっちゃハアハアします。
めっちゃ呼吸を荒くして、僕があたかも心臓の動きが早いように見せかけて、ハイスコアをたたき出して見ます。
行きます！
はぁはぁはぁはぁはぁはぁ
ふほふほふほふほふほふほふほふほ
ほおほおほおほお
あはぁあはぁあはぁ
ほほほおーほほほーほほほー
ほほおーほほほおーほほおーほほおーほほほおー
ぺらっ
あれ。こちらのスコアになりました
まじか！あーゆう人がいるとおそらく低血圧でございます。
次はめっちゃ力を振り絞ってやってみます。
血管の太さなども関係するみたいなのでめっちゃ力を入れて測ってみたらどうなるかやってみましょう！
スタート！
んは！
ぶは！はぁはぁはぁはぁはぁはぁはぁはぁ
お～～～！！
パン!!
来た！すごいスコアです。最高血圧が１８１　最低血圧が１３８　最強レベルですね！
ふぅはぁふぅはぁはぁ　あ、ちょ、待ってホントに血圧上がったはあはあはあはあはあ
１８１！ちょ、やばいスコアでしょ　最強レベルです　多分
やっぱ心臓の鼓動や血の流れってのはたぶん、運動したらかなり上がると思うんでちょっと運動してみましょう！
んは！待って、ちょ、やばやば、死ぬ！まじやばい
んははあはあはあはあはあはあはあはあはあはあはあ
今、今、今しかない、今しかない、はあはあはあはあ
やばいやばいやばい！ハイスコア～
あぁ～？
１５８まで上がりました！なかなか、いい、スコアじゃないでしょうか！
多分おいらがめちゃくちゃ運動した後に帰って来てすぐ測って、さっきみたいに力を踏ん張ると多分300、400くらい行くんじゃないかな！血圧が
次は、運動と力をいれるのを２つ合わせてちょっと最後に最高のスコアを叩き出そうと思います
はぁ…ふぅー
苦しい
ちょっと待って、はあはあはあはあはあ
はあはあはあはあはあはあ
ん～～～～～～～ドゥウ～～この～　ドㇵはあはあはあはあはああはあはあはあ
チーン　チーン
チーン
生まれたときから老化ははじまっています。
小学生でも、血管に傷などがあり、
血管の壁は硬化も始まっています。
健康な生活を心がけましょう。
YouTubeもいいですが、たまには運動もね!!